salut à tous on va se faire un petit
live à l'occasion des trois cent mille
abonnés donc je vais attendre
vous arrivez un petit peu tous vous
l'avez donné le rendez vous il est
quelque chose comme 14h01
vous allez arriver bas ils saluent salut
à tous alors ça commence tout tout tout
tout doucement c'est la première fois
que je fais un live sur youtube m'en
voulez pas parce que je n'ai pas
particulièrement de matériel ou
aujourd'hui pour faire ce live ici je
doit fonctionner que les moyens du bord
gsi mon macbook pro avec la caméra du
macbook pro avec le haut parleur du
macbook pro ils ont pas grand chose on
n'est pas complètement dingue en matos
néanmoins on va quand même se faire ça
comme ça donc voilà on attend que vous
arriviez un petit peu tous vous êtes
quoi 12 pour l'instant ça va arriver par
mois déjà comment est ce que vous allez
ça va ça se passe bien
c'est un exercice très particulier pour
ces trois cent mille vous avez dit
d'ailleurs prenez un petit coup ce qu'on
va avoir une cohérence entre elles et
moi j'en ai mon mon petit verger trinque
avec vous à la santé donc on est dans ce
joli dimanche parce que j'ai fait mon
téléphone il est là bas il est quelque
chose comme 14 heures en deux voilà ça
va regarder ça vient vous êtes de plus
en plus nombreux coucou me suivre tu vas
bien oui j'ai très bien ça va et toi je
suis comme prévu ça fait plaisir merci à
toi il ya aussi damien qui est présent
de plus en plus de monde champagne ou
alors j'ai pas de champagne
ce sera peut-être pas forcément la bonne
idée de se faire du champagne à 14
heures comme ça un dimanche
là j'ai fait un petit siro un petit
mélange maison il n'ya pas d'alcool
comme ça on bafouille pas on est bien on
est à l'aise voilà on est à la cool
salut ça va ouais ça va bien il vous
comment ça se passe plutôt pas mal et
j'espère alors qu'est ce que je vous
propose
on va se faire un petit live a lyon on
tape sur une petite demi-heure et puis
on verra après en fonction de comment
les choses évoluent des besoins de la
discussion essayer ça mais avant toute
chose je voudrais vous me disiez macalou
en tchat
est-ce que vous ne captez bien est-ce
que l'audio et de bonne qualité
est ce que la vidéo est de bonne qualité
est ce que ça rame pas trop ça c'est
vraiment le truc important à savoir
alors ça commence doucement ça va nickel
séoul à la sas raffole du canada salue
au canada lots de bière c'est pas très
loin de chez moi
coucou salutations c'est le regard de
fabien ouais moi aussi je vous aime
heures dites moi si ça va ça bug un peu
ouais ça bug qualité pas top de la vidéo
et je suis quand 4g ici j'ai pas de
croix la vitesse du chat c'est juste
monstrueux je n'ai rien à dire c'est un
petit peu comme qu'est la came troublera
ljg pas une super qualité
j'ai de la 4g sinon j'ai de l'adsl chez
mme autant vous dire que la qualité pas
dingue on se fera d'autres live très
bientôt j'adore la fibre à la maison
alors prends vraiment à quelque chose de
beaucoup mieux avec une meilleure
qualité
là pour l'instant c'était vraiment
histoire de marquer le coup ce soir
passer du temps avec vous je pars
pouvoir discuter avec vous et de voir un
peu comment ça se passait des choses
commencent à aller je vais essayer de
suivre la le chat c'est juste ou fille
sim l'audio est cool c'est déjà ça au
moins on peut s'entendre un peu floue et
ça c'est là la webcam du macbook pro et
pourtant à paris a dans mon studio j'ai
la dernière stringham de logitech et je
n'ai pas là donc malheureusement voyait
que le confinement j'aime pas du tout
bon matos j'ai un éclairage
tiens on peut ont cru en moi se voir un
peu alors est-ce que vous avez des six
simples tout c'est pas grave on va quand
même salle avec est-ce que vous avez des
petites questions imposer ce cas des
choses que de sujets vous voulez qu'on
aborde le nanya j'essaie de voir un
petit peu tape à la wi fi le wifi c'est
pas terrible ici c'est une vraie
catastrophe
j'ai un adsl avec une collection qui pas
terrible je suis beaucoup mieux là j'ai
mon téléphone voyais pas noir il ya une
fenêtre j'ai mis le téléphone à
l'extérieur parce qu'à des murs très
épais dans l'immeuble donc le téléphone
et derrière je suis connecté directement
du macbook pro à l'iphone pour faire le
partage c'est pas extrêmement pratique
mais bon je me dis qu au moins comme ça
on peut communiquer passer un petit bout
du du dimanche son ensemble et ça c'est
quand même plutôt cool alors c'est une
côte est ce qu'il aurait mise à jour de
la batterie du us value trajet plus
d'infos de samsung à ce sujet donc je
vais pas vous vous en parle et et dans
quel coin je suis à clermont ferrand
vous voyez là sans la france
et moi je suis au milieu voilà takk
merci à toi rockstar prod pour ces deux
euros c'est super gentil donc voilà je
suis en plein milieu de la france moi
j'habite là en famille c'est un oui à ma
vie de famille mon studio est à paris
donc forcément voyez je fais souvent les
trajets sauf en ce moment je suis comme
tout le monde
confinées à la maison d'ailleurs
j'espère que ça se passe plutôt pas trop
mal le confinement normalement et si
tout se passe bien pour toutes les
personnes qui sont en france nous reste
quinze jours
de confinement après on va pouvoir
sortir donc ça devrait être un petit peu
plus je vais essayer de suivre un peu le
chat c'est vachement dur
kss kss kss kss kss que beaucoup de
questions sur les smartphones quel
téléphone conseils pour 400 euros il y
en a qui est vraiment pas mal pour 400
euros c'est celui-là je vous en ai parlé
ça c'est le dernier iphone est ceux
d'apple et franchement je sortis ce
matin d'ailleurs une vidéo pour vous en
parler ou je vous conte par l'iphone est
ce qui coûte 4 189 euros et le plus gros
modèle qu'on peut retrouver chez apple
c'est l'iphone 11 pro mac ce qui coûte
1600 euros dans ma config à moi c'est la
version 512 giga je me suis dit que si
vous si ce smartphone mais en tout cas
tenait ses promesses par rapport au plus
haut de gamme par rapport à ceux
retrouvés chez apple
ça veut donc dire que celui là ce serait
vraiment très très bon et un super bon
plan
il puis vous assurer aller voir la vidéo
comme ça vous serez tous mais l'iphone
et ceux de 2020 est vraiment très très
très bon le design par contre est un
petit peu obsolète
mais si on arrive à passer au delà de ça
si vous aimez les petits formats et vous
voulez vraiment un truc super beau en
photo et qui est très parfaitement vous
serez pas déçus sinon après da quand
même pas mal de produits sur android
vous entourent des 400 euros outre
vraiment vraiment de quoi faire ce sont
des smartphones de cette année ou alors
vous pouvez voir 40 vachement
intéressant sur des smartphones de
l'année dernière mais peut-être
construit une vidéo là dessus si vous
voulez si ça vous intéresse bravo nous
sommes 10 pour les trois cent mille cas
merci beaucoup nino c'est vrai que c'est
cool je suis super content qu'on n'est
pas la fête hier soir il était 23 heures
et quelques stages espions c est là le
compteur passe trois cent mille
voilà je vous ai fait quasiment nuit
blanche commençaient pas là au moins on
est là on est ensemble
merci stéphane 5 francs suisses c'est
très gentil super cool alors qu'est-ce
qu'on est debout comme question s'est il
pratiquera hypra dur à lire
qu'est-ce que j'ai alors attendez il est
bien il est bien le gie celle de 2016 il
est un peu parce tu es un logiciel de
vraiment un peu old school au pot find
x2 pro on en parlera bientôt il aurait
dû arriver il ya eu un problème avec la
livraison il peut arriver jusqu'à la
maison mais normalement je devrais très
très très très très prochainement qu'est
ce que vous me dites comment je peux
faire pour arrêter ce truc je n'y vois
un sou
l'humour rien alors attendez c'est de
voir un petit peu au nord view 30 ça on
devrait aussi en parle extrêmement
prochainement y aura pas mal de choses à
dire du côté de chez au nord tac tac tac
ya alors attendez qu'est ce qui se passe
chez one + licenciement j'ai pas du tout
entendu parler de ça je crois pas j'ai
pas vu les équipes de voix de plus il ya
un peu de temps quand on parlait
justement du one piece suite ils veulent
puisque huit pros avant qu'il sorte
j'ai pas de nouvelles à ce sujet là je
t'aurais pas du tout vous dire aucune
info tu as quel âge et 4,40 comme ça
depuis pas longtemps
qu'est ce que vous me racontez il est
bien le dise lui a dit c'est un des
rares smartphone de samsung que je n'ai
pas testé
c'est quasiment tous vu et le à 10
malheureusement je n'ai jamais eu c'est
toujours un peu compliqué vous savez des
fois pour récupérer les smartphones
d'entrée de gamme parce qu'à pas trop de
deux modèles fait pour la presse donc
malheureusement là dessus je peux je
peux vous donner absolument aucun retour
pour l'instant j'ai eu lieu à 20 e
j'étais pas hyper enthousiaste donc
j'imagine que l'adisq sera pas non plus
voilà mais c'est vraiment histoire de
rentrer chez samsung avec un smartphone
samsung avec moi lui aie bon voilà à la
vôtre
ça part bien poux alors qu'est ce que
vous me dites de beau j'essaie d'arrêter
tout ça c'est que ces eaux là là là là
là comment on fait pour bloquer ce chat
à voilà qu'est ce que j'ai tu me
connaissent quoi comme apple pour
commencer des fois j'ai du mal à
comprendre certaines questions qu'est
l'iphone serait meilleur qu android on
peut pas comparer sont deux os différent
il ya du très bon chez android
il ya du très bon aussi du côté d'apple
avec les iphone ça dépend de ce que vous
voulez ça dépend de vos besoins ça
dépend de votre porte monnaie
ça dépend de quel surcoût jeu vous allez
préférer du côté d'android il ya quand
même pas mal de choses qui rentrent en
compte là dedans il faut activer les
mots dralans petits points d'entente
chat ok alors je suis vraiment un newbie
en tchat
si je vois où elle mode ralenti et bien
ça serait vraiment cool parce que pour
l'instant je ne vois absolument rien je
peux remonter un petit peu je regarde
tes plus samsung ou iphone
j'aime bien les deux marques donc
absolument pas tranchée
ça dépend vraiment une fois de plus des
besoins de ce que vous voulez vidéo sur
le sony xperia one 2 j'aimerais bien
mais pour l'instant j'ai absolument
aucune nouvelle de sony là dessus donc
s'ils veulent m'en faire parvenir c'est
avec grand plaisir
je suis au mir et demi note 9 s pour
l'instant il n'y a rien de prévu non
plus là dessus at le may 7 40 progresse
je pense que les choses très
intéressantes aux côtés de siwa cette
année tu es sur paris au clair manche
habitat clairement et mon studio est à
paris donc normalement hors périodes de
coronavirus je suis très souvent à paris
malheureusement voyant ce moment je ne
peux pas y aller et je suis très très
bien la maison
ça se passe bien donc ça c'est cool
iphone et ce2 ou iphone 11 c'est pas la
même chose si on cherche à la fois des
ce2 c'est qu'on veut un petit format on
arrive très intéressant s'il attend vous
voulez le max de performance que vous la
plus grand écran les faunes 11 bien
évidemment on est vraiment sur deux
choses qui sont complètement différentes
qu'est ce que vous me posez encore comme
joly qui sont là encore des questions
sur leurs ennemis note 9 aces mais je
vous dis là dessus si absolument pas
d'un faux timbres au maire si beaucoup
julien elisa moreau s'est permis ni
terminions quoi d'neuf fait les smart
2020 pour l'instant j'ai absolument pas
d'information là dessus tu penses quoi
du huawei p30 lights plutôt bien mais je
trouve qu'il a peut-être un peu vieilli
maintenant et au regard des côtés du p
40 like néanmoins c'est quand même un
smartphone qui est qui et qui peut
encore fonctionner brandon gonzalez je
possède le one + 7 est pro depuis le
début du conflit il ya six l'écoulement
jamais ce smartphone là il franchement
pour comparer à l'alternance promax
l'expérience du celte et pro est
vachement meilleur maintenant en tout
cas j'ai bien aimé aussi
l'année dernière le one + 7 projets
beaucoup utilisé c'était proto citerai
coûte extrêmement proches mise à part la
caméra tu offres mais dans les deux cas
de vraiment très très très bon produit
alors qu'est ce que vous racontez encore
quel pc portable gamer pour moins de
1000 euros je suis pas un spécialiste
des pc portables gamer il faut puisque
taylor la chaîne de mon pote arnaud
arnaud le prénom c'est la lettre c
harmos et vous allez le voir son pote à
moi qu'à lancer une chaîne ya pas très
longtemps et qui lui par contre à une
vraie bonne expertise là dessus et qui a
des tutos qui pourra vous dire vous file
un coup de main beaucoup plus facilement
le samsung galaxy s 'sera vaut-il le
coup oui
le samsung galaxy s envole coup bien
évidemment
je vous ai fait une vidéo je vous parle
du s20 l'es20 de plus je vous les mains
peu face à face pour savoir lequel
prendre et je peux vous assurer que ce
que laisse moi c'est vraiment un
excellent produit je t'aime beaucoup
quand arrive le nouveau black jack 3g à
d'infos là dessus j'ai pas de nouvelles
de l'équipe de blake jam donc pour
l'instant je ne saurais pas de vous
redire
jean la poutre salut jean tu va refaire
développe dès que la situation le
permettra qu'on pourra sortir qui aura
des voyages et des choses j'espère pour
l'instant ça semble un petit peu
compromis à mon avis la fin de l'année
va être un petit peu délicate donc dès
que je pourrai des cordes aura
l'occasion ce sera avec grand grand
grand grand grand plaisir
qu'est ce que vous me dites de bien tu
aimes bien le galaxy s ii 10e
ouais pas mal je vous en ai parlé je
vous ai fait une vidéo savoir quel
smartphone de samsung ht le s 10e et
bien mais je ne suis pas sûr que à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui ce soit vraiment
le smartphone htc sauf si bien
évidemment vous trouvez un prix hyper
hyper canon alors hop là venez voir
ensuite qu'est ce que vous dites là
alors tu penses quoi duo nord 20 et les
montres connecter la montre connectés il
y en a plein de montres connectés ypres
ipray cool moi j'ai beaucoup aimé la
dernière watch actif 2 de samsung
j'aime bien les apple watch ça dépend
bien évidemment de l'écosystème dans
lequel vous êtes
il ya plein de produits mais je pensais
pas gérer organiser les playlists sur la
chaîne allez voir sur la page d'accueil
j'essayais de faire ça un petit peu
mieux donc vous pouvez aller voir et
dites moi d'ailleurs si ce que vous en
pensez si ça vous paraît plus lisible
plus intéressant au mieux c'est vraiment
de regroupées par thème pour qu'on
arrive vraiment à travailler
enfin l'option tout cas voir plus
facilement comme ça tekken tout je
serais curieux de savoir ce que tu
penses de ma chaîne youtube tué par tu
fais partie de ceux qui me donne envie
de me lancer beaucoup déjà merci j'irai
voir ta chaîne youtube a pas plus tard
je veux même petit jeu menottes sur un
petit papier
j'irai jeter un coup d'oeil tac voilà
j'irai voir ça un peu plus tard quand on
aura un petit moment ensuite qu'est ce
que vous me racontez de beaux mais vous
êtes extrêmement d'euros cinq cent
trente et une personnes connectées en
même temps merci à vous êtes d amour d
amour d amour ça c'est vraiment cool
d'avoir une communauté ou mignon
ça vaut le coup la watch actif 2 pour
les non sportifs oui bien évidemment moi
je ne suis pas particulièrement sportif
et je puis vous assurer que la boîte
actives de giffard est aimant bien aimé
lequel choisir entre shiomi midi ses
locaux et un disque de pros le haut pour
phoenix de projets les juges les
découverts dans les locaux de gros pois
à paris mais j'ai pas fais le test
aujourd'hui c'est compliqué de vous
donner mon retour là dessus
tak tak lachlan aus dimanche et plus de
500 personnes au dessus du bravo merci
ça c'est aussi l'effet confinement salut
pour attester le readme x2 pro je sais
pas si je vais texter le readme x2
promet je vous parle d'un smartphone de
rim me qui sortira très prochainement et
restez connectés parce qu'on en parlera
extrêmement rapidement ou à l'abonnement
et puis pour tous ceux qui connaissent à
clermont sais pas si ça vous parle à ce
petit camion afterwork petite dédicace
qu'est-ce qu'on a qu'est-ce qu'on a
qu'est ce qu'on attendait c'est moche
c'est un petit coup d'oeil c'est de vous
réponds bien tellement de messages c'est
fou iphone 10 ou iphone e10 r là je
pense qu'à ce moment là ça dépend à du
prix à quel auquel tu peux le trouver
mais bon alors avec les ronces et ça
exactement clermont tak tak sont
intéressés ça c'est pareil je peux pas
vous dire tout de suite one + 8 to one
je suis le problème je suis trop bien
évidemment le web plus futés aussi
intéressant mais le programme vachement
plus loin un écran de 120 m sur quelque
chose qui est beaucoup plus intéressant
le pde 30 est bien le but 38
fonctionnent encore aujourd'hui il n'y a
pas de souci là-dessus
pensez vous monsieur greu pensez vous
que le iphone serait plus performant que
le galaxy s 10 ça dépend quel iphone ça
dépend si le galaxy s 20 pardon ça
dépend quel iphone bien évidemment il ya
des iphone qui seront plus performants
que le galaxy s vins de base
c'est une question entre la puce à 13
bionic et le sabre à 2165 si vous prenez
verse au canada si vous le prenez chez
nous ça sera un exynos ça dépend bien
évidemment de sa malchance il faut que
tu as posé la question des usages à
savoir quels produits vous allez
préférer quel écosystème vous allez
préférer vous posez pas la question de
la performance pure et dure puisque
arriver vraiment au plafond de ce que
peut faire le smartphone c'est pas tous
les jours
peut-être pour les gamers les plus
exigeants mais pour monsieur et madame
tout le monde voilà on s'est posé vous
plutôt la question
de l'eau est ce plutôt que la question
vraiment du top de la performance pour
pour ça fonctionne le mieux
remy 6 en ai déjà parlé les cherry à
l'iphone 10 l'iphone s2 l'iphone s2
clairement l'iphone disent on est sur la
house bionique
donc on est quand même deux générations
en dessous si tu veux des meilleures
performances c'est le s2 par contre
après c'est la question du format et ça
l'est toujours à comparer avec un début
en tenir compte tu viens par rapport au
prix par rapport aux tailles que vous
allez pouvoir mettre dessus
hop attendez je retourne un petit peu
plus bas
j'essaye de me repérer je suis désolé si
je souhaite plein de questions mais
c'est vraiment pas facile
qu'est-ce que vous marquez de sympa as
tu des infos sur le prochain macbook pro
de 14 pouces absolument aucunes infos à
ce sujet vous savez un peu mais sont
plutôt du genre à vous sortir un truc
comme ça tout le monde découvre en même
temps et ça n'a absolument pas fuiter
une idée de la date de sortie des dits
d'accord anti pose de absolument pas
j'aurais pensé qu'il serait sorti plus
tôt
est ce que dit l'accord garde ça sous le
coude entendre un petit peu que la crise
passe je sais pas je sais pas du tout
j'ai absolument aucune info de dives
accord là dessus aujourd'hui elle se
iphone et ce ou iphone 8
il faut n'est ce pas
et ce définitivement qu'est ce que vous
racontez chéri le nouveau motorola
arrive et annonce du bon tu en penses
quoi
je suis un peu dubitatif parce que
j'aimerais bien pouvoir j'ai vu passer
des choses j'aimerais bien pouvoir le
tester vous en parlez malheureusement
aujourd'hui je l'est pas donc difficile
de se faire un avis mais en tout cas de
ce que j'ai vu ça a l'air assez
alléchant va tout testé la tablette 6
light je pense pas tout de suite mais je
pense que il faut attendre la fin du
confinement pour qu'on puisse me
l'envoyer puisque l' agence qui gère les
envois n'est pas tout n'est pas ouverte
donc il faut que samsung fasse des
envois l'agent ce que l'agent me
l'envoie donc ça se fera mais pas
forcément tout de suite tout de suite
tout de suite tu penses pas du honorera
aujourd'hui le haut normand il
fonctionne encore mais ça dépend bien
évidemment il faut de plus des usages
est ce qu'on vient chercher là dessus
alors qu'est-ce que vous marquez de
sympa j'essaye de de lire très
rapidement mais c'est pas facile
beaucoup de questions sur les iphone ça
je pense que c'est vraiment un truc qui
vous intéressent beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup les iphone wars ou l'écran j'y
vois absolument plus rien aux caisses et
vont faire tout est revenu à la normale
tout va bien monsieur grue pour attester
le lg velvet pareil
j'aimerais bien si c'est possible après
lg en france en tout cas présent sur un
marché français après vraiment laissé
tous les smartphones de côté est-ce
qu'ils vont revenir un petit peu sur le
smartphone avec ce produit là ça reste à
voir
parce que s'il n'est pas dispo en france
à être un petit peu plus délicat pour la
voir donc pour l'instant je ne saurais
pas vous dire tu pourras testé le
samsung à 51,5 j'ai testé lui à 51 à 51
5 g je ne sais absolument pas tout ça
est ce que tu as été déçu de ne pas être
allé au mwc 2020 oui évidemment j'étais
déçu de ne pas aller au mwc 2020 mais je
pense que c'était un mal pour un bien ça
a permis d'éviter que le
le virus est encore plus rapidement et
distribue plus rapidement dans le monde
donc je pense que c'est une décision
très difficile de la part des
organisateurs mais aussi montrée
courageuse et on se fera ça une
prochaine fois bien évidemment tweed et
meurt félicitations pour les 300 cas
merci à toi ça c'est cool
qu'est ce que vous me dites encore de
beaux pour adultes et c'était
prochainement un smartphone de samsung
oui on testera prochainement j'ose
imaginer que ça me saoule sortira deux
nouveaux modèles cette année ils vont
continuer à compléter la gamme j'espère
peut-être un deuxième fold peut-être
parce que si vous allez voir sur leur
site et bien le fold v1 n'est plus en
vente directement il vous redirige vers
des revendeurs donc ça peut laisser
peut-être penser qu un fold v2 puisse
arriver
bon moi je pense que oui je pense qu'il
ya encore d'autres pliable cette année
chez samsung donc il faudra vraiment on
se revoyait soit très très très près
pourrais-tu tester l'iphone 4 je suis
pas sûr je suis vraiment pas sûr de
faire des tests de téléphone anciens
mais dites le moi d'ailleurs si ça
pouvait potentiellement vous vous
intéressez iphone 7 pro obsolète
absolument pas pas du tout obsolète très
bon smartphone beaucoup de questions
sont les iphone il faut être plus le xps
très forte cette année le meilleur pc
2020 peut-être
ça marche
très bien les laisse de dell toujours
très très bon produit taken shot not
huit pros ou red min 9 s je n'ai pas
testé leur éminente 9s malheureusement
je pourrais pas te répondre à cette
question tu peux nous parler du cas des
850 km de sortir dans malheureusement je
suis pas un expert là-dedans allez
plutôt voir mon pote jérôme de la chaîne
d'hôtels qui pourra peut-être plus vous
en parlais que moi c'est pas trop mon
domaine ça je suis désolé allez-vous
faire des test plus complet pour les
télés c'est pas impossible
c'est pas tous c'est pas possible j'ai
eu un brief l'autre jour d'une grande
marque qui fait des télés qui nous a
présenté la nouvelle collection sous
embargo donc toujours pas en parler mais
c'est pas impossible que je vous parle
davantage de télé par rapport à ce qu'on
a pu avoir l'année dernière et en parler
plus en profondeur parce que plus j'en
vois plus j'en parle plus je découvre
plus j'apprends et plus je peux vous
raconter le dessus non mais t'es trinque
à la volaille chine à la santé du
colonel assez de la grenadine
alors ensuite vos petits messages notre
vin va sortir je pense que notre vin va
sortir et c'est du pixel 4a et 5 en or
par absa mais bien bien plus tard quand
tu faire des vidéos pour les objets de
la maison view caméra peut-être
peut-être pour l'instant c'est pas prévu
mais c'est pas impossible même samsung
galaxy z philippe deux pas pour
l'instant le un bien déjà sortir il faut
qu'ils commencent par ce vent avant que
le deuxième arrive un ordi à me
conseiller pour les lycées il y en a qui
est pas mal j'en ai parlé à ce jour
c'est le au nord c'est le magic book 14
pouces 6 à 14 h 15 pouces sont pas mal
très bon rapport qualité prix en tout
côté prise de notes et bureautique je
pense que c'est un produit qui peut être
vraiment intéressant
qu'est ce que vous me dites pour ça ils
leur ennemi notre site web note plutôt
bien il faut prendre un macbook ou un pc
au nord ça dépend ce que tu veux faire
si tu veux un produit plutôt performant
et que tu aimes mac os vaches sur chez
apple par contre c'est quand même un peu
plus cher si tu prends le pc de au nord
tu vas avoir un pc qui va être très bon
pour être bureautique pour ces usages là
mais d'autres usages qu'ils seront moins
bons en août sur un mois loin de toi
qu'est ce que tu peux faire avec un
magot tu conseilles quoi comme écran ça
dépend de quoi tu parles à questions
excuse moi j'arrive pas trop bien à
comprendre xbox ou à genoux ps4 je suis
pas un gamer mais je pense qu'on peut
trouver des très bonnes choses des deux
côtés alors attendez tac tac tac galaxy
s 20 exynos ou à une +8 trop si c'est de
la performance pure si tu parles de
l'exeo st mon avis tu veux parler de
performance pure
je dirais ou en plus huit ponts pour la
performance pure ici vous ne sais pas si
vous avez vu mais l'année dernière ça
c'était vachement intéressant il ya le
classement en tout ou qu'ils fassent un
benchmark en gros pour voir la
performance des smartphones est en tout
ou l'année dernière sans classement vous
trouviez des smartphones nous éloigne
plus froid dans les quatre premiers
c'était du wan plus et fait un truc
complètement dingue là-dessus ce côté
assez dingue à merci borie cerati pour
les 2 euros très gentil de ta part je
regarde un peu les questions les
questions les questions les questions ok
ça j'ai déjà vu hop je reviens par là
quel smartphone à moins de 100 euros
ça c'est difficile de faire un sujet là
dessus ça c'est un super sujet je prends
des notes
ses crayons milk de téléphone à moins de
100 euros
je pense ça peut être un sujet vraiment
bien parce que il ya plein de choses à
raconter
et il ya plein de pièges dans lesquels
il faut pas tomber non plus pour pas
jeter tout et n'importe quoi ils
pourront pas être déçu qu'est-ce que tak
tak tak le rythme x5 en propre à 165
guest pas évident de suivre en même
temps il pouvoir tout vous répondra
merci les respecter ce pas je peux
travailler à temps s'il te plaît régler
les n'y a qu'en ouais je sais que c'est
pas du tout comment ça marche tout ça je
découvre vraiment le live facebook je
suis pas du tout au point aujourd'hui
monsieur greuet ce que vous pouvez
parler de l'évolution de nubia je suis
pas encore bien au fait de l'évolution
du gars je vous en parlais prochainement
j'ai déjà testé un produit du bien je te
fait en tester un autre je sais pas si
je vais le recevoir donc c'est un peu
compliqué pour
vous en parlez les loups qu'est ce que
vous me racontez debout au tac tac qu'un
oui voilà mon pari de boîte plus
justement brandon gonzalez qui me dit
effectivement oui le one + 7 des pros et
éclat troisième au classement dans tout
ce qu'un début 2020 non mais ils ont
vraiment fait une razzia et dernière
exemple m en fait un boulot assez
incroyable en plus avec une belle montée
en gamme avec la version pro c'est
vraiment cool iphone c'est nul pour les
jeux absolument pas la seule chose qu'on
va avoir alors ça dépend si tu me parles
de l'iphone et ce qui est un petit écran
c'est pas à toi la meilleure expérience
mais si tu prends un iphone
11/11 trop gros max avec la puce à 13
bionique tauromachie très performante
après la question c'est est ce que la
petite encoche sur le côté il a growth
d'ailleurs encore chaud côté te dérange
ou pas sur tout ça mais en termes de
performances en appel de quoi faire chez
apple c'est des machines qui sont
extrêmement bien optimisé qui marche
vraiment très très bien donc pour les
iphone ça marche bien voila apres c est
ce qu on ait maillot et c'est ce qu'on
aime apple pas la question se pose
plutôt plus de ce côté là à mon avis un
féroce
le red mica 30 déjà sorti en chine je
veux surtout tester les smartphones
sortie en france elles sont européennes
parce que vous parlez d'un produit
chinois que j'ai pas dans les mains
c'est un peu plus délicat à mon avis
qu'à tac tac tac que tu penses quoi de
l'arrivée du duo de microsoft android je
suis très impatient tout a été un petit
peu repoussé je constate que son 2021
maintenant qu'on le verra mais je suis
très impatient de voir ce que microsoft
nous propose là dessus parce qu'il
s'était manger le nez un peu cassé le
nez ya quelques années sur smartphone et
ça peut être une intéressante ça pas
forcément un smartphone c'est un produit
un petit pic et j'ai vraiment voir de
quelle manière vraiment hâte de voir
quelle manière ils l'ont ils l'ont
intégré ça va être intéressant
tu penses quoi de la marque midi j'ai
déjà testé des smartphones du midi j ai
des points intéressants
j'en ai pas testé récemment donc je veux
pas trop me prononcer ce que j'avais vu
était encourageant il y avait encore un
peu de taf mais c'était assez
encourageant mais tout n'était pas
complètement il y a
[Musique]
je lui plais message merci dit in show
kurosaki pour les 2 euros
j'ai impétrantes pro je veux passer
aurait plus eu trop tendance quoi je
pense que le one + 8 pro est une petite
petite bombe atomique donc si tu le veux
tu peux y aller il faut montrer très
très bien je tiens je cherche des
messages
vous mettez tellement de chose merci à
vous cet attachement dur de pouvoir un
coup de griffe de répondre à tout homme
attendait qu'est ce que vous me racontez
là mon pote olivier meilleur smartphone
européen et stopper le boucher ça c'est
un vieux surnom le boucher meilleur
smartphone européen je peux pas répondre
à ça olivier meilleur smartphone
européen c'est compliqué il ya plein de
bons smartphone meilleur smartphone
européen tu veux donc pas rien d'une
marque française a fait une marque
propre et m qui de toute façon sera
fabriqué son smartphone en chine ou en
inde en tout cas en asie
donc ça veut dire la conception et le
marketing ici on va retrouver nokia
qui a encore des smartphones ici on va
trouver cros coll j'aime bien la
proposition mais c'est vraiment de
l'outdoor donc c'est très particulier il
ya un hic au ricoh qui est une
entreprise française sous capitale
chinoise et hino donc qu'est-ce qu'ils
sont encore complètement français ou pas
mais ya que les épices des équipes
soient françaises il n'y a plus rien de
fabriquer et c'est ce que je te disais
l'autre jour olivier quand on parlait
par message sur facebook messenger et
bien il ya tout qui pètent pas mal si tu
te poses la question est ce que c'est
pour sa compagne en fait qu'il veut un
smartphone avec une conception
européenne
eh bien je pense que le mieux est
d'aller jeter un coup d'oeil du côté de
chez air phone j'étais pas tester donc
pas vous dire ce que j'en pense mais sur
le côté un peu éco responsable le côté
où on prend soin de son smartphone eh
bien ça peut être ça peut être pas mal
réduit la vitesse aurélien acac dit cote
salut à toi je vais essayer de quoi de
parler un peu moins vite
je peux parler un peu moins dit ça je me
suis complètement incapable merci gare à
toi comme dit-on fiston être des raisons
agid ça c'était marrant lejaby ça dans
la vidéo je trouvais ça rigolo comme
monfils et disait abonne toi la chaîne
de mon papa sinon gare à toi
il avait trouvé l'idée y perdre ton ipad
rôle de ces ip et de rendre un petit
garçon un peu tu es mieux comme ça
qu'est ce que je trouvais ça drôle
tony dupont salut à toi te dis merci
pour les 2 euros je suis de retour après
une longue absence et bien ce sera le
bienvenue et merci à pouvoir si tu peux
faire des live je pourrais te filer un
coup de main pour activer le mode
ralenti du chat écoute well why not on
se regarde à une prochaine fois jeudi
mme aubry ferait un peu tout ça on verra
ça tranquillement ensemble
j'ai essayé de me prendre me faire un
peu la main ça fait cool de prendre ces
petits moments s'envoyait mieux répondre
à toutes vos questions
ce que je ferais par contre lorsqu on
refera tout ça j'irai récupérer à paris
dès que j'en aurai la possibilité dès
que les autorités donneront
l'autorisation
j ai récupéré du matériel et notamment
une nouvelle webcam on aura une bien
meilleure qualité que je le vois un
espèce de truc là moi c'est pas très
glam mais bon moi se permet de nous voir
et nous entendre une fois de plus à la
vôtre on est déjà à 28 minutes de live
c'est absolument incroyable ça passait
une vitesse merci à vous de votre
présence des répondre présent
aujourd'hui c'est absolument incroyable
je peux pas vous raconter le truc c'est
sale descriptif bruit parce que je suis
une petite parenthèse dans tout ça mais
moi j'ai commencé ma chaîne youtube fin
2016 quelques années déjà j'avais déjà
des cheveux blancs et en fait on se
retrouve tout seul face à une caméra
magescas larmoyer chez cette petite
caméra j'ai mon panasonic mon gh5 que
j'aime beaucoup et on pas une caméra
donc c'est une grosse différence entre
ce film et montée publiées et fois
qu'elle est publié et bien c'est génial
parce que je vois que ça vous intéresse
peut lire vos commentaires je peux par
vos interactions et du coup on c'est
génial sauf que pour moi à ce moment là
au moment où j'ai publié mise à part le
fait de voir vos commentaires et bien
c'est terminé et je réfléchis déjà la
vidéo suivante dont je suis déjà dans
autre chose
donc en fait je profite pas de l'instant
je profite pas de pouvoir vous répondre
et pouvoir être en toute l'interactivité
avec vous et c'est ça qui est
complètement génial avec un live c'est
que ça me permet de profiter de
l'instant de cette manière là merci
alexandro pour les 5 euros qu'est ce que
tu mets comme question pourquoi si peu
de téléphone compact sur android je vais
te réponds je fais une petite pour les
vidéos non partisane avec plaisir la
question de fait de ne plus avoir de
smartphones compacts
ça répond à un usage grandissant depuis
des années c'est le visionnage de
smartphones et le gaming sur smartphone
donc les constructeurs cherchent à avoir
des smartphones de plus en plus grand
pour avoir une meilleure qualité de
lecture qu est-ce qu on passe plus de
temps à regarder nos smartphones pour
une série un film dans les transports en
commun que pendant un moment pour
divertir
donc on est obligé d'augmenter la la
taille de l'écran pour avoir une
meilleure qualité de visionnage une
meilleure expérience puisque
effectivement le premier point qui est
le côté multimédia le côté visionnage de
série de films et réseaux sociaux qui
est vraiment le premier gros points qui
est extrêmement important et le deuxième
gros points sur lesquels travaille
vraiment les constructeurs c'est le
gaming le divertissement et pour les
personnes et plus je dirais les plus
hardcore entre guillemets si on peut
dire ça comme ça c'est effectivement les
gens que j'avais la meilleure expérience
de gaming avec beaucoup de performances
et de la fluidité d'où le fait d'avoir
des écrans standards hier ce qu'on
retrouve actuellement le fut d'abord des
haut parleurs stéréo et compagnie donc
on est vraiment dans cette idée là
dans la mesure où on est dans ses usages
les usages grandissant eh bien il faut y
répondre avec des smartphones
grandissant donc d'un côté je pense que
c'est les smartphones qui crée les
besoins de ce côté là mais aussi des
besoins auxquels les constructeurs
essayent de répondre
donc c'est pour ça aujourd'hui qu'on a
des smartphones plus grand et moins
compact et c'est aussi pour ça puisque
ça devient plus grand et d'un compact
que certains constructeurs et notamment
apple le fait dernièrement et bien
retourne sur des smartphones plus
compact pour ne pas délaisser non plus
un public qui ne veut pas des produits
trop grand mais ça ça correspond
aujourd'hui à moins en moins de
personnes
voilà voilà comment moi en tout cas je
vois les choses bravo aurélien trop fier
merci à toi trop mignon tac tac tac tac
alors la question de modération des live
pourquoi pas on se verra ça sur plus
tard parce que pour l'instant je suis
encore un petit peu un petit peu loin de
tout ça que penses tu du dodji n20 j'ai
absolument aucune aucune opinion tout de
suite parce que je le je n'ai pas testé
c'est très compliqué de vous donner mon
point de vue là dessus je suis
influenceurs et youtuber en situation de
handicap
salut à toi force et honneur qu'est ce
que vous me racontez de beaux tac tac
tac tac
tu penses quoi de youtube heures éric
vais lui déconseille tous les nouveaux
smartphones de honor pour les non geeks
je me connecte pas eric vais les non
geeks geek c'est un mot qui est un petit
peu comme être beaucoup de choses dans
big il déconseille tous les nouveaux
smartphones de honor pour les non geeks
braves
moi je suis pas nécessairement d'accord
avec ça parce que tous les nouveaux
smartphones de honor ça dépend quel
smartphone de au nord il ya beaucoup de
gamme chez au nord donc ça dépend ce
qu'on veut à qui se destine
après vous pourrez prendre et même un
produit qu'on pourrait imaginer plus
pour les geeks ou pour les non geeks et
bien je pense que tout un chacun peut y
trouver un petit peu son bonheur donc je
pense qu'il faut pas être aussi
catégorique est vraiment essayé de de
nuancer et c'est comme ça en tout cas
que je vois plus les choses
il y aura-t-il un samsung galaxy s 38
l'année prochaine
même si c'est pas forcément la
dénomination en tout cas oui il y aura
un galaxy y aura un galaxy s iii
j'en suis persuadé oculus quest oculus
trift j'ai pas testé le rift mais le
coin si les tester et j'ai beaucoup aimé
l'expérience sans fil j'ai beaucoup aimé
bon j'ai pas testé un cast je teste
certains casques fait un peu d'audio pas
beaucoup mais un petit peu tu me
conseilles quoi comme pc de mon pc
portable pour le montage à moins de 1500
euros
je vais pas te conseiller un pc en
particulier je vais te conseiller de
chercher quelque chose de très
performant beaucoup de ram un disque dur
suffisamment grand pour pouvoir tout
stocké à l'intérieur et pas galérer que
des projets cherche plutôt quelque chose
dans cette idée là parce que tu prends
trop de choses intéressantes à
différents chez différents fabricants
mais à mon avis c'est plus ça l'idée en
fait la question est posée c'est
vraiment la performance la fuite et le
stockage et après le meilleur rapport
qualité prix c'est souvent une question
de budget bien évidemment alors qu'est
ce que vous racontez encore il ya plein
de choses là là là mais vous en avez
choisi raconté huawei watch j'étais 2e
qu'en penses tu j'ai alors la ouate gt2
je n'ai pas testé j'ai testé son
corollaire chez au nord je pense que
huawei honor ou encore un peu de boulot
à faire notamment au niveau de leurs de
leur os de leurs montres pour pouvoir
avoir pleins d'applications et pour que
ça devienne vraiment beaucoup plus
pertinent est beaucoup plus intéressant
après je le prends du calme et assez
cool tu vas faire un pseudo tu es 13
essais 10r membres de la team dreux
merci à toi c'est quoi ton téléphone
personnel en ce moment et bravo pour
nombre d'abonnés utilisent depuis
quelques mois
l'expo dont ceux promax ça faisait très
longtemps utilisé plus d'iphone et quand
apple m'a proposé de l'utiliser sur le
sur le moyen et long terme
je me suis dit why note puisque
j'utilise moi un macbook pro pour
travailler je le trouvais qu'il y avait
un nuage a vraiment tester ça comme ça
est vraiment voir comment l'écosystème
d'apple avait vraiment évolué entre une
apple watch entre le macbook pro entre
l'iphone promax qui est dehors en train
de bronzer au soleil et qui permet
d'avoir la connexion entre un ipad pro
comment cet écosystème s'articuler et
c'est pour ça que ça fait un petit
moment que je suis là dessus
et voilà mon téléphone personnel il y
aura aussi un iphone quoi la plus tard
de voir un autre iphone qui sortira bien
évidemment au mois de septembre
je vais acheter le sony xperia one soit
on teste merci beaucoup ok j'ai une
saison 2 est-ce que tu pourras faire une
vidéo plutôt vers la rentrée de
septembre pour des pc portables pour les
cours en école sup est vrai que je crois
pas sa patte une idée effectivement de
faire ça de faire des des tests de pc
pour vous orienter sur de l'achat
peut-être sur la fin de l'été pourquoi
pas ça c'est un truc vraiment envisagé
je regarderai ça je peux dj h je peux te
demander un conseil pour mes contenus
youtube sur l'accessibilité numérique
écoute j'ai acheté un petit coup d'oeil
à la chaîne tout à l'heure je me dis ça
et on verra est-ce que tu connais glg
greg le geek
alors j'ai sg je sais pas si c'est la
même personne ou pas pas peut-être ça
aurait peut-être
j'ai déjà fait passer des choses j'ai
déjà vu il ya un petit moment je crois
tac tac tac tac qu'est ce que vous
racontez
est-ce que l'extension tp link qui a on
parla de connexion wifi à la maison est
ce que l'extension tp-link à une plus
grande portée ou qu'une extension normal
ou c'est juste depuis haut débit en fait
je vous ai fait une vidéo le jour pour
vous parler je pense qu'il faut que tu
parles bien des septs elle s'appelle
wifi germait depuis a parlé c'est lé
wifi moi je les utilise chez moi j'en ai
mis en là j'ai mon studio qui en dessous
ça me permet de bien dispatcher pour moi
c'est vraiment l'histoire de dispatcher
correctement mais déjà à la base de la
base de la passe qu'il vous faut chez
vous c'est une bonne connexion internet
puisque vous pouvez prendre le matos que
vous voulez ils ne feront pas de magie
si à la base vous n'avez pas un débit
suffisant bien vous n'avez pas le créer
mais en tout cas moi ce produit-là de tp
l'insee ce que mon bureau c'est ça la le
déco j'ai mangé le nom des liens
s'appelle comment déco voilà c'est plus
brefs enfin ça c'est pas mal j'utilise
et j'en suis assez satisfait alors
ensuite qu'est ce que vous me racontez
une vidéo 90' vs60 rd 120 hertz avec les
smartphones compatibles
je suis pas sûr tu vois que ça soit plus
pertinents on comprend la question de la
fluidité on comprend qu'on va
effectivement plus de fluidité avec du
120 hertz tout du 60 hertz il 80 yards
c'était un petit peu entre les deux je
sais pas si faire une vidéo que pour ça
pour vous le montrer ça soit réellement
pertinent je sais pas j'ai pas convaincu
pourquoi on peut plus envoyer de vidéos
en messagerie qui peut réponse on peut
commettre vidéo messagerie
j'ai du mal à comprendre ta question le
prix d'une hotte 10 va-t-il baisser
d'ici six mois je pense oui que le prix
d'une diva va baisser puisque un modèle
en poussins autres françois cogné bravo
pour les trois cent mille cas tu le
mérites merci à toi françois c'est
extrêmement gentil il ya tellement de ce
panel est tellement de messages me perds
tac tac tac fera tueur test du lenovo
yoga si lindsay tu sais pas prévu c'est
pas prévu mais peut-être pourquoi pas
beaucoup de produits sur les smartphones
alors attendez peux tu me donner à
l'instant notre coin salut ça va mais ça
vas y toi tu peux me donner des conseils
pour les jeunes youtuber de teck
alors en fait moi je vais vous donner un
point de vue global si vous voulez faire
des vidéos sur youtube
il faut pas le piège et on est tous
tombés dedans moi le premier et c'est
que quand on commence des vidéos sur
youtube
on commence parce qu on est vachement
inspiré ou hype et para les personnes
qu'on regarde et on dira waro que j'ai
envie de faire ça du coup on fonce on se
jette et on fait souvent un peu la même
chose que les autres et c'est normal
c'est normal mais en fait là où certains
arrivent à se démarquer et à trouver
leur voie
c'est justement en trouvant leur propre
voie ce qui est extrêmement important
lorsqu'on fait des vidéos
lorsqu'on constate sur youtube que ce
soit sur instagram que ce soir où vous
voulez il faut que vous soyez différent
il faut que vous soyez vous même puisque
la chose la plus importante c'est la
valeur vous allez apporter
c'est pourquoi il faut vous répondrai à
cette question pourquoi est ce que
quelqu'un viendrait de regarder
viendrait m'écouter viendrai moi c'est
vraiment la question à se poser c'est
souvent on a la mauvaise réponse parce
qu'on répond parce que moi je fais ici
c'est non et il faut vraiment faire
cette introspection ce travail là
quelles valeurs je vais apporter
quels conseils je vais apporter quelle
plus-value je vais apporter par rapport
à ce que les autres en place font déjà
donc si vous faites la même chose que
les autres vous ne pourrez pas
fonctionné puisque vous ferez la même
chose que doc qui sont déjà plus connus
donc pourquoi je voudrais vous voir vous
il faut vous trouviez votre propre voix
notre propre style ne copiez pas les
autres osez les choses il faut faire
quitte à se planter vous pourrez
toujours rectifier mais si vous faites
la même chose que les autres vous aurez
beaucoup moins de chance d'avancer
rapidement donc trouver votre propre
voix votre pape chemin soigner
différents ne fait pas la énième chose
et on retrouve beaucoup sur youtube et
ça se comprend parce que c'est pas
forcément facile de trouver sa propre
voie
mais c'est vraiment la clé la clé la clé
la clé après il ya toujours des
questions techniques de la mode
miniature du bon petit tout ça tout ça
mais dites vous bien que la question
essentielle le point essentiel c'est
votre valeur votre valeur votre valeur
votre malheur le reste après ça se
travaille toujours
alors on revient là dessus qu'est ce que
vous oubliez le loup samsung est sera
ultra ou
suis trop à ça c'est une question un peu
coquine ça dépend ce qu'on veut ça c'est
une question un peu coquine ça ça s'est
un peu compliquée le xv a eu 35 peu de
l'oeil quand même là je vous cache pas
que l'ess valtra il a quand même des
arguments que le one piece huit pros n'a
pas même si j'adore le web le site pro
trouve que samsung a vraiment fait un
très bon boulot là dessus merci franck
des landes un poil et 5 euros
on a la bonne vôtre
alors attendez qu'est ce que vous me
racontez tac tac tac tac tac tac tac tac
tac à maël j'ai un ami qui un cpl chez
lui avec la fibre optique et le cpl ne
marche pas dans sa chambre tu sais
pourquoi
si un cpl ne marche pas ça vient très
probablement d'un problème
d'installation électrique puisque pour
caen cpl fonctionne il vous faut une
bonne installation électrique ça pour
moi c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment
important titre de la vidéo qu'elle si
yao me ht en 2020 c'est prévu c'est dans
les tuyaux vous inquiète pas j'ai 22
mille inscrits lots pattaya hockey et
ben écoute ça c'est cool tac tac tac que
penses tu de la 5g
c'est un sujet très intéressant là
samedi on en reparle à moi la 5g
je trouve ça intéressant intéressant non
pas pour gagner en vitesse et perdre en
latence et enfin je recommence non pas
pour gagner en débit et réduire la
latence qui déjà sera en première et et
il serait intéressant surtout pour ce
qu'on va voir plus loin dans dix ans le
fait du tout connecté
ça peut être un peu flippant il faut que
ce soit fait correctement ce soit aussi
géré par les états mais je pense qu'elle
est vraiment des belles histoires à
raconter il peut y avoir de très beaux
progrès que ce soit en termes
d'industrie en termes de médecine en
termes de pour rapprocher les gens pour
rendre les choses plus intelligent plus
simple et plus efficace pour moi ya
vraiment de belles choses à raconter là
dessus maintenant il faut pas que ça se
fasse au détriment des questions de
santé publique
donc il ya une vraie interrogation à se
poser là dessus mais sur le principe pur
de la 5g
je veux aussi une très belle évolution
maintenant il ya toujours des raisons de
santé publique derrière
est ce que c'est bon ou mauvais il faut
des vrais études il faut vraiment
pouvoir avoir un vrai recul là dessus et
malheureusement moi je ne suis pas
compétent dans ce domaine là mais son
côté purement technologique
je trouve ça génial monsieur gros je
t'aime moi aussi je t'aime merci web et
40 proche et aux milices pro à
ça aussi c'est une question très coquine
parce que les deux sens quand même
vachement cool j'ai trouvé que huawei
waouh excuse moi soit shiomi a fait une
montée en gamme vraiment impressionnante
avec son v10 projet tester les miss très
prochainement d'ailleurs on se regardera
ça bientôt mais crash suis un peu embêté
que cette question je suis vraiment un
peu embêté parce que pkr pro il est
aussi cool il fait plein de belles
choses
moi je pense que la question en fait
elle va pas se poser en termes de photos
parce que les deux sont très bons les
deux ont chacun un peu leurs
particularités et les deux sont cool la
question va se poser maintenant par
rapport aux services google parce que
c'est vraiment là que la différence va
se faire
est ce que pour vous c'est un problème
de ne pas avoir les services google et
d'utiliser la bière et comme ici sur le
b 40 po voyez-vous leur spécialement
pour l'occasion
ou est ce que pour vous c'est pas du
tout un problème est que ça vous va très
bien fonctionné que la galerie que les
applis la suivrons bien que google vous
en fichez cas limites vous avez anti
google c'est vraiment pour moi là dessus
c'est bien la question à se poser et je
peux pas tranché comme ça est ce que
c'est vraiment le point le plus
important pour venir comparer ces deux
produits
julien tanguy salut julien toi salue
monsieur grue bravo pour les transformer
cas merci peux tu faire une vidéo
que valent les macbook air 2015 2017 en
2020 ça c'est une question intéressante
je suis pas sûr faire une vidéo comme ça
ne ju lien je suis pas sûr parce que on
va se faire une vidéo sur des produits
qui datent 35 et 3 en jeu c'est entre
nous un macbook
il est fait pour durer minimum 5 ans tu
peux le garder 5 à 7 en disant tu as tu
es quand même bien tu vois ce que je
veux dire ça c'est possible
donc c'est pas impossible donc si tu
achète un mac book air 2005 il est déjà
allé entre la moitié et les trois cartes
sa vie si tu l'achètes bien évidemment
d'occasions donc il ya déjà fonctionné
ça paraît normal puisque apple ne vend
pas des produits neufs de 2004 jusqu'aux
larmes suite à une béquille qui bug est
en fait c'est moi qui peut donc acheter
un macbook air
même si tu le payes pas trop cher alors
qu'il ya potentiellement 2 3 4 ans durée
de vie
tu vois je me dis que
il vaut mieux investir si c'est souvent
une question d'argent dans une machine
qui sera un peu plus récente essayer de
voir comment on peut la financer
plutôt partir sur une machine qui va
être un petit peu trop anciennes trop
obsolète et qui est un moment risque
dramé puisque si tu veux un macbook air
ça pourrait faire du montage pour aller
faire de la vidéo c'est plus pour aller
faire laden bureautique est ce que un
macbook air est vraiment le bon produit
de faux sur une question de budget un
peu plus vers le bas ou est ce qu un bon
produit microsoft
enfin il fonctionne sur windows sera
peut-être la bonne solution moi je le
prendrais plus de ce côté là soit c'est
plutôt là cette manière que j'aborderai
le problème au pot watch bientôt
peut-être peut-être peut-être peut-être
quel smartphone pour 300 euros
tellement c'est compliqué comme ça brûle
pourpoint samsung la galaxy
à 51 ans est un bon produit il y en a
plein d'autres c'est celui qui me vient
en tête tout de suite meilleur jeu par
trois notre 1000 euros il y en a 1000
euros on est dans le trio de garde le
meilleur c'est compliqué c'est après
savoir quelle est la surcouche android
est ce qu'on est maillot s est ce qu'on
veut de l'android c'est là dessus que je
me pose vraiment la question plutôt toi
qu'est les meilleurs smartphones de 2020
de ton point de vue de milan ni même pas
la moitié
on en parlera à la fin de l'année il ya
eu très très belles choses anthony favre
maintenant le meilleur je peux pas le
dire je peux pas tout dire qu'elle est
c'est toujours la même question mais
mettez plus en plus la question bande de
petits coquins la tac tac tac tac
ok ça marche alors attendez on va
regarder je retourne un petit peu plus
bas apple pas en dessous de 17 et 16
giga sinon c'est mort
moi je suis assez d'accord avec ça il
faut de la fluidité sur une machine
sinon c'est compliqué moi j'avais un
macbook macbook pro un vieux modèle de
2011 que j'ai gardé jusqu en 2018
il est mort du jour au lendemain j'avais
monté l'arabe se passer de 4 gigas de
ram et 8 giga drame raconte papa exploit
je faisais des montages là dessus en
full hd
j'arrivais mais bon y'a un moment ça
tire un petit peu il faut quand même de
la faim gros gros minimum de ram sinon
il ya un moment où on n'y arrive plus
android webos c'est une question
extrêmement personnel moi j'aime bien
les deux ça dépend une fois de plus
après de ce qu'on veut comme produits et
de la surcouche parce qu'il ya quand
même beaucoup de choses différentes chez
android
mais elie béart saluer monsieur gros
j'adore ce que tu fais en termes de
présentation merci à toi je trouve que
tu es le meilleur tu m'écoutes merci ça
fait très plaisir ou en plus sept
témoins de plus suite sachant que le one
plus cet été va baisser en prix le one +
8 ce sera plus performant cet été
maintenant le one plus sept t3 oui tout
de suite
ok on tranche fois de suite monsieur
gretay génial merci à toi continue comme
ça j'ai regardé j'ai commandé le macbook
air 2020 il 5 pour de la m à au web
dis-moi silva fait une bêtise
non je pense pas si tu me colle je sais
pas combien de piste sur logic audio
arrivera un moment où peut-être tu peux
être un peu limité en ram mais tu peux
déjà faire plein de choses avec de
l'argent et mao c'est de la musique
assistée par ordinateur la plana pour
ceux qui ne seraient pas on préfère
quand même pas mal de choses moi je
pense pas que t'es fait une bêtise
après ça dépend effectivement de la
taille des projets ça dépend de tes
fichiers tu m'aurais dit de la vidéo je
t'aurais dit mais là dans la musique je
pense que c'est parce que tu peux y
aller dans plus qu'ailleurs belle mise à
jour très prochainement rien vous dire
encore du côté de certains logiciels de
apple donc je pense qu'il ya des choses
intéressantes à raconter là dessus salut
c'est pour savoir si ça vaut le coup de
prendre un iphone 8 ou 7 en 2020 tests
est meilleure demain si paul ps
est ce que ça vaut le coup on va pas
avoir la meilleure performance
on va avoir des puces un petit peu
ancienne maintenant c'est la question de
se dire je veux un iphone je ne le
paient pas trop cher est ce que ces
smartphones la fois encore la faire moi
je te reverrai partira millimes minimum
sur le 8 puisqu'en termes de photos le 7
il ya quand même vieilli
le 8 ca aussi vieilli mais c'est comme
si tu acheté un iphone 10 je dirais que
si tu touches à un bon prix pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas mais si c'est qu'une
question de prix et que tu veux juste un
bon smartphone et biens en question ont
pris tu prends ça et ça c'est vachement
cool métissée du cac 2,7 pouces je crois
moi en tout il est vraiment bien
vraiment derrière vidéo tu verras
franchement il est vraiment vraiment
bien je vouloir ton avis pour un
projecteur marqué je ne sais pas du tout
compétent sur les projecteurs je suis
malheureusement désolé je ne pourrais
pas t d est ce que tu comptes
d'intéresser un peu plus dans la vr et
bien peut-être pas aujourd'hui encore
parce que il ya certaines choses mais
que l'averse intéresse pas beaucoup
beaucoup de monde je pense que la verve
vraiment se développer avec l'arrivée de
la 5g
on ira plus loin en tout cas on n'y est
pas encore il ya encore beaucoup de
progrès à faire mais on en reparlera et
on suivra ça dans tous les cas me why do
c'est bien je ne peux pas te répond tout
de suite meilleur smartwatch compliqué
il y en a plein de très très joli ça
dépend bien évidemment il faut de plus
de l'écosystème c'est une question
d'écosystèmes souvent les smartwatch
qu'elle montre pour 100 euros
j'avais fait une vidéo qu'elle montre
connectés acheté par 80 euros je crois
vous pouvez jeter un petit coup d'oeil
ça peut être pas mal
il ya des choses pas mal il faut voir à
100 euros allez jeter un coup d'oeil ils
voulaient ces fossiles
je sais pas s'ils ont des produits et à
ce prix là c'est pas mal ce qu'ils ont
chez fossiles ont plein plein de bonnes
choses au catalogue voulait déjà 49
minutes bon sang de bon sang c'est
encore 464 c'est absolument incroyable
merci à vous est extraordinaire nous
sommes trop nombreux temps délaissé et
m'a regardée alors ensuite testera tu le
sens experia un mac de gispert tac tac
tac tac tac
pourquoi en 720p je suis moi pierre j'ai
dû louper une partie de la question
parce que j'ai du mal à comprendre ta
question utilise le blackjack de pros
dans la vie de tous les jours non tes
attentes pour l'iphone 12 a beaucoup
d'attentes notamment au niveau de
l'encore plus petites plus réduite
notamment sas et on a bien des points
essentiels tac tac tac qu'est ce que
vous me dites montaigne de tuyaux
cessibilité des jeux axés 2
trouver des sujets qui puisse intéresser
tout le monde est mon pote matt xm salut
félicitations pour être ensemble il
cassa du mythique scène c'est pas que tu
vas bien vote à l'île maurice on s'était
vus j'avais fait une vidéo
allez voir la chaîne de matic ça lui
parle de teck et on s'était rencontrés
cet été j'étais en vacances et il m'a
dit wes on peut se voir et où je dis ok
mais qu'on la trouve un petit moment et
puis il était venu me voir on est une
vidéo sur sa chaîne et on avait passé un
très bon moment ensemble aller voir sa
chaîne s'attaque à la bonne vôtre
les amis bons et dites moi vous un peu
ou est-ce que vous habitez là parce
qu'on parle de teck de produits mais
parlez moi appel vous mettez moi
laon commentaire enfin qu'ils veulent en
dessous vous aidant le chat ou est-ce
que vous habitez vous ou est ce que vous
êtes
faites-moi avoir c'est un petit peu
alors attendez qu est-ce que j'ai ou
est-ce que vous habitez tak tak j'essaye
de suivre un peu je n'arrête pas de dire
tac tac je suis désolé pour ceux du
verbal il absolument ridicule je peux
projet tak tak reims à reims reims
nantes non j'ai beaucoup d'idées sur les
plusieurs fois lyon j'ai vécu une partie
de ma vie à lyon brive je connais aussi
j'étais là dessus j'ai la famille à
tulle la bretagne la bretagne ça vous
gagne à lyon à la réunion très cool la
réunion saint malo très jolis endroits
dunkerque amiens mulhouse tarn limoges
annecy j'adore annecy c'est très très
très jolie toulouse ici l'année dernière
pour la première fois j'adore maurice
salut maurice paris
j'adore aussi qu'est-ce qu'on a
qu'est-ce qu'on a pattaya créteil
danemark assez cool le danemark la
guyane whaou bon courage à toi c'est
loin la guyane aurillac aurillac j'ai
aussi plein de potes qui sont médecins à
aurillac saint nazaire nice bordeaux
strasbourg moi j'ai de la famille à
sarrebourg pas très loin clermont
ferrand comme moi ambert ambert ambert
c'est très drôle en bercé ma famille
vient d'ambert ma mère est née en berne
pas moi voilà qu à brunoy génial salut
comment ça va au cameroun vous adore
jouer à tout le moins qui sont sur le
continent africain
québec aussi gros bisous à nos potes
québécois
jura suisse epinal suisse à mon pote mr
perrier en suisse van van très jolie
j'ai une copine qui a vécu longtemps à
vannes la vendée j'aime beaucoup si la
vendée très sympa un peu de géographie
comme ça on en profite
le marseille de la famille à marseille
dispo que j'y aille
bientôt quand on pourra quand
confinement sera levé quand on aura
droit de voyager
et quand il n'y aura plus de risques
voilà la russie a cool la russie je
connais pas du tout jamais allée de ma
vie chalon sur saône très bien j'y suis
déjà allé également aix en provence il
ya un musée granet à aix-en-provence je
m'appelle aurélien gradés et il ya un
musée qui porte mon nom
absolument rien à voir avec moi mais ça
fait toujours plaisir quand je vois ça
montpellier j'aime beaucoup aussi brigue
vs clarmont rugby clermont baby bien
évidemment s'en douterait lille lille
j'aime beaucoup aussi j'ai des potes de
là bas côte d'ivoire côte d'ivoire j'ai
un pote un pote ivoiriens j'ai connu
quand il fait ses études en france qui
est là bas donc gros bisous à la côte
d'ivoire tu acquiers jaffa tac tac
il faut que j'arrête avec ces espèces de
de tic verbal qui sont absolument
ridicules wet look je suis allé en
guadeloupe j'aime beaucoup la guadeloupe
c'est vraiment très très bel endroit les
gens sont d'une gentillesse absolument
incroyable je pensais retrouver un de
ces quatres portugal porto et cardo je
suis à la porte aussi j'aime beaucoup
cette ville c'est vraiment un endroit
qui est magnifique
bruxelles je suis pas 100 avions je ne
connais pas châtel guyon assez pas très
loin de chez moi ça le maroc mais maroc
beaucoup très joli pays l'algérie j'ai
beaucoup l'algérie j'ai de la famille en
algérie hma ma famille elle est à
mostaganem
voyez le gabon bisou au gabon en chine
williams a noté carrément loin toi un
bisou en chine et cei paf paf paf pif
paf ça y est chez soi que ce soit mieux
mais je peux essayer ça qu'est-ce qu'on
a le japon japon tamesna vous êtes quand
même vachement mais quelle heure il est
chez vous ça ne pollue moins incroyable
d'où viens tu as you grow jeunes
clermont ferrand moi je suis jeune
auvergnat pur souche un vrai bouya vous
voyez saint-barthélemy salut à toi c'est
pas coter non plus la suisse tournus
savez vous êtes quand même d'un peu
quatre coins du monde c'est vachement
sympa belgique roumanie roumanie je ne
connais pas je connais la bulgarie à
côté je suis allé en vacances chez des
amis congo kinshasa
et ben moi ça c'est vachement cool ouais
j'ai toujours des messages adorables de
plein de personnes qui me suivent et qui
sont en afrique
et ça ça fait aussi toujours chaud au
coeur moi j'aime beaucoup l'afrique moi
je suis allé ma première fois en afrique
c'était en 2003 j'ai passé un mois à
abuja nigeria et j'ai je tombé amoureux
c'était très particulier parce que
c'était très compliqué il y avait des
militaires partout armés tous les côtés
je vous en ai parlé dans une vision dans
une toute première vidéo de ma chaîne
sur le chercher nigeria sans ma chaîne
vous verrez et c'était une expérience
absolument incroyable j'avais 23 ballet
et j'ai adoré adoré adoré adored jamais
vraiment retourner ce continent africain
je sais pas où peut-être en côte
d'ivoire j'aimerais bien y a pas un
endroit qui me tente vraiment je sais
pas où mais on sait qu'elle fait ça
c'est sûr maroc moselle voilà oui à ma
famille ben voyez donc même pas mal
endroit tu as quel âge d'ailleurs j'ai
quarante balais bordel de bordel pas
très jeune allez on à 56 minutes dans
quatre minutes ont un gros bisou et je
vous laisserais partir à vos activités
on se pose encore quelques petites
dernières questions si vous le souhaitez
stade toulousain pas et s'aiment mais
non elle sonne bien évidemment tu rigole
ça c'est les vieux les vieux combat de
deux équipes de rugby mostaganem ya ma
famille à mostaganem
est-ce que vous avez des petites
questions allez on y va ça lui aurélien
je reçois mon one + 8 trop de mains et
je voulais savoir comment faire la
première charge merci à toi pose pas
trop la question de la première charge
on n'est pas dans l'idée vous savez de
se dire qu'il fallait décharger à fond
puis de recharger à fond pour ça marche
aujourd'hui on est plus dans ces
questions là tu prends ton smartphone où
tu mets ta puce et quand tu vois qu'il
faut recharger tu leur charge t'inquiète
pas il y aura absolument aucun problème
tout ira bien
quarante ans déjà les cheveux blancs
j'avais des premiers cheveux blancs là
devant là j'avais 20 de 23 ans 24 ans ça
commence et puis volé depuis le boulot
c'est cette huile en plus avec avec le
confinement c'est bien remplir ouais
ouais
as tu un pc portable pour le montage de
vidéos cool non une fois de plus s'est
il trouvé de la ram de la performance de
la performance de la performance n'a pas
de la famille asper ce nom je n'ai pas
de famille avec personne et pas loin de
chez moi j'en ai pas
qu'on crée un camp dit score pour ta
communauté
j'utilise pas discorde j'ai un vrai
problème aujourd'hui mois c'est le temps
parce que je passe tout mon temps à
travailler et je me suis engagée déjà
plein de projets et j'ai des fois je ne
savais pas les tenir donc me mettre sur
un discorde sans qu'elle vous iriez vous
pour qu'on passe du temps ensemble et
que je sois pas au rendez vous non je
pense pas peut-être jours on verra
aujourd'hui c'est malheureusement pas à
l'ordre du jour
quels produits apple pour faire de lyme
ou vie la question c'est de la vidéo ça
des mêmes sur animaux vite par des
projets un peu gourmand il faut de la
ram moi je pense que pour faire de la
vidéo aujourd'hui faut un macbook pro il
évoque 16 giga de ram 32 c'est bien il
minimum 512 il ya de stockage parce que
sinon tu vas être rapidement dépassée
que penses tu de l'android dise pas que
du bien de détails que fais-tu tout le
matos que tu reçois la plupart du matos
que je reçois sont des modèles de presse
qui repartent
il ya la kmz longue je garde d'autres
non ce que je garde les conserves pour
faire des tests vous comparez avec les
modèles des années précédents mais je ne
revends rien si la question est là je
garde tout bien au chaud monsieur greuze
jeunes en featuring peut-être une
prochaine fois que mon pote jo ann oncé
jamais encore un grand bravo pour trois
cent mille merci à toi très très grand
plaisir le meilleur téléphone à moins de
150 euros on fera une vidéo là tu
reviendras on regardera on regardera ça
est ce que tu me conseilles le paie 40
pro je te le conseille dans la mesure où
la galerie te convient et où tu t'es
usage par rapport notamment à google ne
pose pas de problème sinon oui c'est un
très bon smartphone qui marche très bien
c'est vraiment ça la question à se poser
aujourd'hui avec les smartphones de
huawei qui ne sont pas équipés de google
vous travaillez seul il seul tu fais de
la moto pas trop en ce moment mais
normalement ouais j'ai une vieille
ducati monster 795 qui est au garage ton
équipe est au complet va lire aider
l'équipe est au complet
elle est là elle se situe là l'équipe le
au nord 20 pro et bien on reparlera
d'honneur très prochainement très
prochainement très très prochainement
que penses tu là la samsung galaxy tab
est 5e bien pour le divertissement
divertissement aller nous reste 30
secondes est l école est potes à passer
ensemble tu vis de youtube où tu es un
boulot à côté ça fait on est quoi alors
n'en 2020 c'est depuis septembre octobre
2018 que je suis à 100% sur youtube que
je ne vis que youtube
avant je travaillais à côté et sortait
toujours une vidéo par jour en
travaillant côte est ce dû faire des
choix et je travaillais la journée entre
elles soit je monte je tournais pas cet
hymne c'était une ville pas possible
mais en tout cas c'était cool
romain de techno and test et monsieur
grue pour une vidéo de gros délits de
paul ans après sa part romain pourquoi
pas se faire une petite vidéo acrobates
calorique que je lui en parle tu
cherches un monteur ouais je cherche un
monteur pour l'instant je vous cache pas
qu'avec la situation du couronne avait
rugi tout mis en stand by parce que je
veux c'est d'avoir un peu plus de
visibilité voir ce qui va se passer à
l'avenir
mais effectivement je cherchais un
monteur alexandro hadji abdou merci pour
les 5 euros il m'envoie comme message
pour une application pour ta passion
autre coup tu m'as merci à toi ça c'est
extrêmement gentil aller 2-3 et à la
question et puis après on arrête
laissez-moi jeter un petit coup d'oeil
un petit coup d'oeil au petit coup de
vieux petit coup d'oeil quelle est ta
formation initiale et boulot j'ai pas
réellement de formation initiale je vous
le faites très rapidement très
rapidement j'ai un master 2 en
management des activités culturelles
audiovisuel que j'ai passés par une vae
donc par rapport à mon expérience j'ai
fait de la radio quand j'étais jeune kim
khlie a parlé devant un micro on ne sait
toujours pas trop envie pas pas trop
vite ça c'est le défaut qui revient
encore aujourd'hui donc j'ai vraiment
bossé là dessus j'ai fait de la radio ça
c'était vraiment très très très très
très formateur ensuite j'ai fait une
formation musique ça c'est un peu autre
chose j'ai monté mon premier média web
avec des potes c'est un média sur les
sorties loisirs
on a développé sa jeune et relancer un
peu plus tard que se trouve la vidéo
et puis j'ai travaillé dans le marketing
marketing en pharmacie un pote qui avait
une pharmacie qu'ailleurs toujours une
pharmacie mais une autre ou plus
robotique et hills et du marketing pour
vendre de la parra j'ai travaillé avec
lui donc j'ai toujours été un peu dans
l'univers du web un peu de vidéo
et puis après j'ai tout appris sur le
terrain tout appris sur le terrain tu
peux nous montrer ton burnat nolifes il
est à paris le maire hénault l'ifi
malheureusement pas ici allez une
dernière question
et puis je ne sais pas s'il va dimanche
tranquillement ça fait plus d'une heure
qu'on est ensemble ça absolument prem's
a passé une vie tellement absolument pas
compte
alors à paris on trouve une bagarre
questions qui pourraient intéresser
beaucoup de monde et après un bisou une
claque et au dodo qui fait qu aux fesses
j'adore des vidéos continue comme ça
merci à toi tu essaies d'en garder un
petit peu
quelque chose qui pourrait intéresser
quand même pas mal de monde flagship
avoir en 2020 ça c'est trop compliqué
parce que l'année n'est pas terminée
ton tel personnel c'est le 06 pas
pourquoi j'ai un bug peut pas dire ça
j'ai donné mon numéro directement comme
ça t'en d'été c'est moi regarder bon
dimanche à tous merci beaucoup merci à
toi aussi
j'essaye de trouver quel huawei honor
acheté en 2020 ça pourrait faire l'objet
d'une vidéo effectivement ça pourrait
faire l'objet d'une bonne vidéo bravo
pour tout ce que tu fais bonne journée
merci à toi merci beaucoup saluent bravo
au nord
qu'en penses tu en général allez on va
s'arrêter là dessus moi je pense
beaucoup de bien de au nord en général
on a la même problématique avec huawei à
savoir est ce que vous vous sentez de
franchir le pas d'un smartphone sans la
galerie aujourd'hui c'est vraiment la
question à se poser au nord propose de
bons produits sont des produits qui sont
destinés à un public un peu plus jeune
c'est vraiment la stratégie le coeur de
cible de 2 au nord les produits tienne
la route
il ya une gamme qui est quand même entre
l'entrée de gamme
le haut de gamme donor on a quand même
des produits un peu intermédiaire je
trouve qu'ils font des produits
intéressants
plutôt cool mais une fois de plus la
question à se poser c'est la question de
la galerie vs le bleiz store et savoir
si vous ça peut vous convenir voilà sur
ce je vous fais un gros bisou il me
reste un petit fond de verre à boire je
vais le boire et trinquer bien
évidemment à votre santé j'espère que
oui
ce premier live vous aura intéressé dit
moi dites-moi marqué le mois tout de
suite est-ce que vous êtes content de
slide est ce que vous souhaitez qu'on
fasse d'autres live je pense que vous
voyez le truc et c'est souvent reproches
qu'on fait et je le comprends
j'en conviens parfaitement monsieur gros
tu ne réponds pas aux commentaires tu ne
réponds pas si on commande un fait n'est
pas assez présent tu n'es pas assez
tranchant pour ta communauté peule je
sois pas ça promet pour la communauté
mais je ne peux pas répondre au
commentaire de temps en temps j page
d'un petit message mais j'ai un gros
gros problème de temps puisque comme
vous le savez comme je voulais dire en
tout cas que je travaille tout ça c'est
quand même relativement compliqué mais
je pense que ce format là voyez qu'on
est là aujourd'hui comme ça et bien sûr
le souhait de se faire une petite faq ou
un live comme ça ça peut vraiment venir
pallier à ce problème là puisque je
poste des jeux bien chez des questions
je réponds à vos questions ça nous
permet en même temps de passer du temps
ensemble
un temps convivial en tout cas moi
j'aime bien donc dites moi ça peut vous
tentez qu'on se fasse à chaque fois une
fois par semaine tous les quinze jours
ça pourrait avoir un sens ça pour être
bien et moi voilà tout ça plutôt cool
donc ça c'est chouette et puis quand je
vous parle bien évidemment des problèmes
des commentaires auxquels peut
difficilement répondre je vous parle
même pas sur twitter de tous les
messages privés des tweets comme s'il
doit répondre
instagram les messages privés facebook
les messages privés jeune âge mais
jeunes d'âge mais je vous raconte même
pas comment je nage je suis en auto
crowley dos crawlé c'est comme ça donc
on lui suffisant donc rouler et je vois
là donc si je voulais pouvoir vous
répondre individuellement il y aurait
deux possibilités de pas 3 2 soit je
fais une vidéo tous les trois jours
ils répondent tous les messages ça veut
dire que en termes de de productivité il
ya vous créez du contenu je suis pas bon
mais par contre je réponds tous les
messages soient je vois pour embaucher
un community manager c'est pas moi qui
vous répond et auquel cas on perd le
lien et ça ça m'intéresse pas non plus
donc je préfère qu'on trouve la bonne
solution pour avoir le lien et je pense
qu'en format live comme celui là dans de
meilleures conditions avec une vraie
webcam avec un audio probablement
amélioré je pense que ça peut être
vraiment un truc intéressant et un
rendez-vous qu'on peut se donner se dire
maintien tel jour tous les tous les tous
les gestes et reviendra tous les
dimanches à 14h on se retrouve enfin
live ça peut être une idée et je pense
qu'il peut y avoir un sens donc dites
moi si ça vous tente
et en tout cas bien moins une fois par
semaine voyez pas raison et non je pense
que ça peut être pas mal effectivement
une fois par semaine ça peut être une
bonne
donc pourquoi pas je vais étudier tout
ça a tendance à vous remercier une fois
de plus a toujours plus nombreux
toujours plus nombreuses plus de 300
milles c'est pour moi c'est absolument
incroyable
laissez-moi jeter un petit coup d'oeil
voir combien il tout de suite la sspa
connecter dessus vous le dire enfin
voilà bon on est très nombreux vous
voyez sur les compteurs donc merci à
vous d'être toujours plus nombreuse
toujours plus nombreux merci à vous de
répondre présent merci à vous d'avoir
pris sur votre temps pour venir
aujourd'hui passé sept heures ensemble
center qui pour moi est passé très vite
c'est un exercice tout nouveau de vous
parler comme ça pendant une heure et
répondre aux messages donc je crois
j'adore l'idée j'adore ça vraiment on
est là on est ensemble on est en live et
peut-être qu'on se fera ça très
prochainement dans meilleures conditions
avec un bon éclairage avec un bon micro
tout optimisé dans studio est à mon avis
reçoit ces choses vraiment cool sur ce
je mets mon petit curseur sur arrêter la
diffusion
je vous embrasse je fais de passer un
excellent dimanche prenez soin de vous
la période est compliquée pour tout le
monde
avec ce confinement avec ce virus de
merde il faut le dire comme ça il n'y a
pas d'autre terme excusez moi pour la
vulgarité mais cette astra ça mettra du
temps mais au final par y arriver
donc je vous souhaite d'être patient de
prendre soin de vous prenez soin de vos
proches et puis quand on se retrouve
très vite pour qui n'aime pas les
textures youtube bisous ciao